america's crime crisis getting out of
hand in states like california where
dangerous repeat offenders are returned
to the streets to cause even more harm
this morning i spoke to a former los
angeles prosecutor irene lee on the
terrifying 2020 attack against her by
the same man who was charged with
assaulting nearly blind and nearly
blinding olympian kim glass turns out
the suspect had assaulted at least three
other women prior to attacking lee and
glass here she is
unfortunately right now at this time
there's a climate of
preferential treatment for violent
offenders over that of law-abiding
citizens i believe that kim's attack was
entirely predictable
and preventable
you know this shouldn't have happened to
her i had warned the judge who sentenced
the man who attacked me when i spoke out
last summer
and i had asked the judge i said how
many more women does this defendant have
to hurt
for it to matter to this court
and that comes amid another story of a
repeat criminal this one ending in
tragedy former nascar driver bobby east
stabbed and killed at a gas station by a
homeless man who was out on parole with
a warrant for his arrest a swat team
later shot and killed that suspect
identified as 27 year old trent milsap
judge i
every monday almost every day we could
do stories like this and it was
interesting for after we interviewed kim
glass on friday
irene who had also been assaulted by the
same person reached out and said you
know this happened to me too and she's a
former prosecutor yeah
yeah you know all this social justice uh
nonsense and it is nonsense the idea is
that everyone should be treated equally
no they shouldn't there are some people
who show you their hand ahead of time
and they victimize other human beings
it's totally unprovoked it's random and
they get a charge out of it and whatever
the reason is there are judges on the
bench there are now these new
progressive prosecutors who think oh
they just need little understanding we
have to let them out we can't
incarcerate them there are some people
who don't deserve to breathe the same
air that you and i breathe and it's as
simple as that they're called career
criminals these people are people who
hurt other people that's why we have
parole boards that's why people like
george gascon should be out of a job
right now in los angeles these are
people who believe that privilege should
be given to the criminal and the victims
don't matter i have long said it
shouldn't be called the criminal justice
system it should be called the victims
justice system because but for the
victim there is no system these
criminals decide that they're gonna
they're gonna hurt any one of us for no
reason and like a thunderbolt it will
hit you and your life will never be the
same they deserve to be behind bars
there's a reason we have this system and
there's a reason why black lives matter
the organization and all this nonsense
is that america is as violent as it's
been in 30 years because they don't
understand the street and greg what
about a woman's right to stay alive yeah
this it's the irony of like where the
hell are the feminist groups because the
predominant number i mean it seems to me
you know many of these crimes almost
most of them are women victims and all
of these perps have a thing in common
they're recidivists right which means
that their subsequent crime could have
been could have been prevented if law
enforcement kept them behind bars i mean
these are guys when you look at the dude
that just killed the race car driver you
look at him they go you wouldn't release
that in the prison general population
much less the american general
population they are playing with
people's lives but if you shared these
examples to woke prosecutors uh they
would simply accept it because they
already
accepted it there were there were
interviews i believe it was with gasco
early on that said that they were
expecting you know a a measure of
recidivism because that's the price you
pay with prison reform you know it's
just something you got to deal with i'm
sure you know there was i think there
was i can't remember who it was so i
don't want to say who it is who
basically said that we're you know we're
willing to accept this risk so i just i
believe that they should
they should experience the risk
themselves i don't know like like it's
not it's not enough to recall someone
there has to be consequences you know
for allowing people to become victims
they have deemed victims subservient to
the victimizers and they gotta pay
legally or i i don't know what you do
but you've got to dissentivize these
woke prosecutors somehow i don't know
how you do it but what about jessica do
you have any ideas on that
i i'm not sure about
what happens post uh being recalled to
your point greg i don't i don't
know what that should be i think that
they're going to have hard times getting
good jobs after they're out of this i
don't think they'll be able to go into
some cushy
you know private
firing chassis is trying to go uh be a
commentator but i think that people
who are on the other side of this people
in public office like gavin newsom was
interviewed by local fox out in los
angeles he was asked about george
castron and he said that he quote didn't
know enough about his job performance
but the criticism is disturbing to him
well
the pictures speak for themselves of
what what's going on you do know the
number of people who left your state
right a lot of high earners who are also
gone elsewhere at this point um you can
follow the story along with everybody
because this isn't something now that is
only being covered by certain aspects of
the media everyone is concerned about
this because you also have high profile
people you have a race car driver now
this happens
a goldman sachs employee who shot the
shot going to brunch on a sunday uh so
we need better responses i i don't know
in terms of punishments for this but
people like irene lee there was a woman
who used to work um in the da's office
in uh san francisco who quit to join the
recall effort
for london breed that's going to be
happening and these are smart
accomplished women right who are making
this argument to your point
when does my life matter yeah and
that's what we're all thinking walking
around hope jessica doesn't get canceled
for saying that yeah please
what would you do if i got cancer oh i
have a few plans
uh when a black mentally ill homeless
man
attacks a asian woman
and a black woman the left thinks wait a
second who's the real victim here
because these two women you have a
successful female asian attorney you
have a black female olympic athlete
they've done well
in this corrupt american racist
capitalist system
but the mentally deranged black homeless
drug addict is the victim
of america's injust system so therefore
he's the one that needs special
treatment because if you send him to
prison you're just re-victimizing him
and everybody knows when you put someone
in prison it creates more criminals so
he's going to need free housing he's
going to need free health care and he's
going to need free magic mushrooms so he
can deal with all of his demons that's
how they see things now you're right
they asked newsom what's going on in l.a
and he basically said i don't know
you'll have to ask the locals
la is in california can you imagine
if they asked desantis what was
happening in miami
i asked people in miami i'm not really
sure
gavin newsom if he's gonna run for
office he's gonna get attacked for
everything that happens in la and san
francisco he better have a better answer
than i don't really know what's going on
i don't think he didn't know or he
didn't want to get into the ideological
army i think he doesn't want to get into
it
of course he knows and he's not brave
enough to say what he thinks opportunity
be the tough on crime guy yeah if you
want to run does anybody want to take
that mental mantle
it's ideology a mental mantle we're
having a monday i'm mentally handling
monday
apparently hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now